thank you so much it really is a
pleasure to be here I appreciate the
opportunity to to tell you a little bit
of of what we've been doing and I'm
going to talk to you about using
non-invasive brain stimulation methods
combined with other imaging modalities
and neurophysiologic measurements to try
to characterize and modulate the brain
networks but in a broader sense I wanted
to share a little bit of how how we've
been thinking about sort of
translational opportunities and frankly
the need of greater integration between
basic sciences and clinical activities
before I get going these are my
disclosures I'll tell you about
applications of non-invasive brain
stimulation that are off-label and we've
been blessed to have funding from a
number of institutions the most
important disclosure is that the work
I'm going to tell you is done by a lot
of people probably except for myself and
and I'll tell you I'll try to tell you
anyway
who is done the work when I when I share
specific experiments but it's it's a
pleasure to work with with all of them
so it's but Stickle says when i say we
assume them and when i say me assume
they and you'll be you'll be good okay
so I'm going to try to argue that that
the proximal cause of the symptoms and
disabilities of patients I'm a cognitive
neurologist it can be found in its most
proximal cause that dysfunctions of
specific networks and that
characterizing the dynamics of those
networks provides fundamental insights
into the neurobiology of the symptoms
and disabilities as well as
opportunities to help the patients and
I'm going to try to show you that the
brains militia in general and
specifically non-invasive simulation
allows us to characterize those networks
query their time
and also deliver personalized
neuromodulation with therapeutic
potential in order to do that I want to
talk first a little bit about
localization of the symptoms and how we
can modulate in networks and and you
know that I'll be talking about non
invasive methods and the main two that
I'll talk about is transcranial magnetic
stimulation and transcranial current
stimulation and I think you're you're
all familiar with with those techniques
there deceivingly is similar and very
different ultimately in transcranial
magnetic stimulation uses
electromagnetic induction to do so
current in the brain it is electric
electrode less stimulation via
electromagnetic induction transcranial
current stimulation comes in different
forms and flavors you can apply direct
current alternating current at specific
frequencies or random noise stimulation
and fundamental it's always between at
least two electrodes if not more
it is thus rather non-focal and and it
is more of a farad icing of the brain in
that there exort see the effects I told
you I'll try to frame it from the point
of view of translational science and and
traditionally in the approach has been
to do research fundamental basic
research gained some insight and look
whether and how it can be translated
back into the patient's or forward into
the patient's I'm going to try to argue
that at least the opposite direction is
worth contemplating if not a better way
to go about it
Miller bias I'm a clinician ultimately
and so I'm going to try to argue that if
we define carefully the symptoms and the
disabilities rather than simply put a
diagnostic and
city label on a patient instead of
saying Parkinson's or depression we
identify the problems that the patients
have and their network dysfunction that
we can then reverse engineer the problem
a inform basically research and then go
back to the patient is sort of enough
one symptom based approach to research
so that's that's the product that that I
try to argue we start with the
localization of symptoms present many of
you know this fellow Constantine for
Monica of you publish a they're very
nice I think a conceptual framework of
how we should be thinking of
localization of symptoms in in Neurology
is largely forgotten a book he's
remembered because of the arcuate
fasciculus that he described and the
concepts of dioceses that most of us
know well but at the level of
localization he argued that localizing
the lesion is not enough that knowing
where the lesion is may be necessary but
it's not sufficient to explain a
patient's suffering in an symptomatology
that one needs to go from the lesion to
the impact that the lesion causes on the
rest of the brain what he called
functional localization hence those
notions of their species and then
address the question of how that rest of
the brain deals with that functional
impact leading to the notion of symptom
or disability localization I'm going to
try to show you that we actually have
the tools in our in neurology to fulfill
those requirements of localization that
the constant in front monarch of
theoretically presented and that if
do that we have new ways of approaching
therapeutics in in patients in order to
do that let me start with a patient so
this is somebody that presented to the
emergency room at API with Vivid well
form elaborate colorful visual
hallucinations she described that all of
the sudden upon waking up she had been
having preference and then suddenly
started seeing these people and animals
very well defined sort of awkward sort
of weird
there was a little elephant on her
breakfast table which she knew shouldn't
be there but she couldn't help but
seeing him so well formed well define
clearly an uncertain typical environment
and and it wasn't just visual either in
the elephant for example started moving
and in doing so she was convinced I was
going to tap onto the things on the
table in fact felt sort of childlike
sensation you guys know what that is
some of you clearly know in classic
neurology knows it's not a new thing it
was described first by Thunder meat in
the turn of the century in 1922 on a
woman also with very similar story that
what I just described and we call it
peduncle or hallucinosis it's a
oftentimes thought to be related to a
stroke additionally in their mid thought
maybe in the peduncle don't ask me why
because we know that it has no visual
relationships but the hand-wavy
explanation given is that the lesion
there or whatever the lesion is must be
the afferent thing or releasing visual
areas and thus those the afferent the
visual areas must trigger this visual
symptomatology the person seeing the
patient was say our boys and this fellow
here and they and he called the chief
resident and told him this story and him
they talked about the explanation he
said surely that's not satisfactory
right
I thought well work for me for many
years why wouldn't it be satisfactory
it's just a perfectly good hand-wavy
explanation him and he said well but
maybe we can we can get better at it so
start with the lesion in this particular
case the lesion is here in the thalamus
in fact often times the lesions in these
patients are in the thalamus
but it's not in a visual part of the
thalamus and it's a stroke oftentimes
there are strokes so that that causes us
the symptoms and and that clinical
picture what Aaron did was gone to
collect a number of cases all of these
cases that had lesions in different
parts of the brain but what they had in
common is the same clinical presentation
the same sudden onset of well form vivid
visual hallucinations with a diagnosis
of peduncle or hallucinosis with no
other prior strokes and you can see that
they are sort of all over the place the
traditional way of trying to make sense
of this from a lesion localization
approach would be to take each one of
those lesions put them in an atlas and
overlay all the lesions and they come up
with a picture serve like this with nice
colors that tell you the majority of the
lesions that cause these peduncle
hallucinations are located in the area
in red there and some do happen in the
brainstem but if you look all these
cases only six have actually an overlap
most of the cases in other words
actually don't overlap so what you've
gotten out of the lesion localization is
a perfectly good explanation for a very
small minority of the cases and left
untapped the vast majority of the
patients even though clinically they
have the same manifestations and so the
alternative way that they mike fox and
our employers thought about trying to
localize is go after this for monarch of
concept of functional localization take
deletions of these different patients
localize the
Atlas and then instead of overlap them
map them onto a database of a thousand
individuals with resting state
functional connectivity data and ask the
question if you have a lesion there in
wherever that there is for the different
patients what impact would it have on
this individuals functional connectivity
on the resting state functional
connectivity and so you get for each
patient a different pattern and you can
now overlap that information so the
functional networks and what you do that
when you come up with is this picture a
local high connectivity of positive
correlation around the thalamus in two
areas of anti-correlation suggesting
that or implying that when you have a
lesion in that area activity in these
areas would go up in these areas are as
many of you have recognized now really
in visual areas in fact they map onto a
visual motion in area MT b5 and the
implication might be that if you target
those areas you can suppress activity
there you may relieve those visual
hallucinations which is indeed what
happened in this patient that I was
telling you about and targeting is
possible with narrow navigated TMS
let me show you another example of the
same type of approach if the approach is
they call the lesion Network mapping and
these are this is a study of Simon
dragon ear and what Simon is interested
in is in freezing of gait and so again
you can have the sudden onset of
Parkinson's like freezing of gait but in
response to a stroke to stroke that
oftentimes happens in all kinds of
different locations from basal ganglia
to brainstem localizations and you can
go around about the localization issue
in the same way as I just described for
the particular hallucinosis if you
overlap deletions there is no overlap
but if you overlap the networks that
they impact there is an overlap and in
fact only one that accounts for almost
all 50 11 out of 15 patients and that
maps onto the cerebellar area which one
go into it but but maps onto the
cerebellar a sort of gate area and if
you look at the functional impact
functional connectivity of that area
think symptom localization in the full
monarch of framework then what you get
is this network associated with those
lesions or those localizations India
allows you to identify areas for example
here in the supplementary motor cortex
that is reachable to stimulation so I've
tried to show you with these two
examples that we can take lesions
wherever they are identified and network
impact that they have and in doing so
targets for brain stimulation directly
or identify overlaps of functional
localization and then from there the
network that is impacted and again
identify the targets I've told you it's
hard to show I've told you what happens
when you target this area in people with
brown color hallucinations at least in
an N of one Aaron was able to suppress
the hallucinations in the patient it's
really not any treatment that we have
otherwise so so it may make a difference
in let me show you what happens in
freezing of gait when you target this
supplementary motor cortex this is
somebody that that will take awhile in
trying to walk through the corridor
because of frequent freezing episode
it's a very disabling symptoms even in
Parkinson's disease
it's a disabling symptom that oftentimes
we don't have good treatment for you
know medications dopaminergic
medications don't really improve
freezing of gait or freezing of movement
in the upper extremity and deep brain
stimulation to the subthalamic nucleus
is a very effective as it is for motor
symptoms
it doesn't really address oftentimes the
freezing components if what you're going
to see in a moment is what happens to
the same person after the stimulation to
the identified targeted area let me
fast-forward in the interest of time so
he keeps getting frozen gets stimulated
for 20 minutes and this is him
afterwards
[Music]
if we could do that reliably and sustain
the effect it'd be awesome we can't but
at least not yet but but I hope that
that the example illustrates the fact
that we can identify the functional
localization of the symptoms at least in
this case of the freezing of gait
component and modified modulated acutely
then there is all kinds of challenges
obviously of how to really turn it into
a therapy that if all you get is this
that wouldn't be very satisfactory but
at the very least it might provide a
approach where you can identify then a
target to implant electrodes if that's
what it would take and and they provide
a more lasting effect
[Music]
now sometimes just the stimulation
repeatedly can they're non-invasive
simulation repeatedly can lead to
lasting benefits and so if we give you a
another example work that is from from
some time ago
done with a mercy money nazar this is
obviously the fMRI of somebody sort of
talking in in a scanner in identifying
the broker and Wernicke's area and the
connection between them would be that
out wait for siculus that that from
monarch of describe we have a stroke
like this largely taking away the entire
supply of the middle cerebral artery
then it raises a question of how you're
going to recover if you do at all in
this is the person with that stroke and
this is Robert Missouri know him I have
his permission to show the the video
he's going to talk ten years after the
stroke
so he shows what traditionally would be
described there's a non fluent more or
aphasia or a Broca's aphasia him he has
lack of fluency single words or a couple
of words sentences lack of grammatical
words lack of verbs and clearly word
finding difficulties but hopefully you
got the message across of what he did he
he worked in a hospital at Malden
hospital and he started working there in
construction then he went up up up the
ladder and became the vice president of
the hospital for construction before he
had this stroke ten years before this
this video him now when he is in this
kind of trying to talk and this is a
pattern of activity in him there is
obviously the lesion and note the
typical areas we would find it because
they are damaged but there is some funky
areas around and in the left hemisphere
and a lot of activity in the right
hemisphere and the first question is
what is he actually talking with him
that's the functional localization kind
of question that they for Monica would
put back right to start with what is his
motor output message for stringing along
phonemes coming from one way to ask that
question to query that question is to
block this area's target them with nor
navigated TMS systematically and ask the
question which one when block causes a
speech arrest in any cases this is the
most activity here factories in the
literature suggestions that the right
hemisphere may contribute to the
recovery maybe that's that's what it is
there is a famous case from Harlow from
years ago within a child that had a
hemiparesis in an aphasia similar to
Papa Serena's and then had a second
insult from it back in the car daddy's
that's the thought that caused a
left-sided hemiparesis now so a
presumably right hemispheric stroke that
took away the recovered speech he went
on to have to pass away and have autopsy
and the lesion was here him so is that
him is that the substrate it turns out
when you target all these different
areas there's only a single one that
causes a speech arrest and it's that one
him perhaps because of that what Bob
Missouri no notice is is that when he
tries to speak if he tries to do this
while speaking he can't do it he has a
speech arrest or he has to stop moving
him is that a sort of lack of resources
or an oval of of resources I don't know
but but it allows us to localize at the
level of symptom localization of
Lomonaco in what the output speech is
supported by but it also allows us to
target these areas and modulate them
suppress them or enhance them and ask
the question is he able to speak better
with any one of these interventions and
I want to draw your attention to this
particular area I mentioned briefly for
Harlow's case is the parse triangular is
on the right side and when you
repeatedly apply simulation to the
darién suppress it it doesn't have a
speech arrest in fact what happens is
that he's able to speak better and I'll
show you that in a second and and what
he is showing at a functional MRI level
is a lot of suppression of the activity
that was previously there in the right
hemisphere and an increased activity in
that area in the left side that when
blocked will cause a speech arrest let
me show you what that looks like in
behavioral terms he's trying to name
items that are presented on a screen
there are line drawings that we know he
knows the words off but in
unlike many patients with this type of
modern and fluent aphasias in a deadline
procedure a situation they break down
and so if you give him sufficient time
he'll come up with a word but if you
give him a deadline procedure you'll
hear periodically a beef when the next
picture shows up that that expectation
maybe alone is sufficient to make it
harder on him and he comes up with four
out of 16 words I won't belabor the
point there but it's it's a long video
of very little voice from from him him
but sorry but let me show you him
afterwards after that suppression of the
parser on Hillary's speech output is
certainly better more fluid he starts
also having faster lexical access and he
comes up with twelve out of the sixteen
words again this is just an acute effect
this will last for ten minutes and and
then it's it's gone but it's not just in
him it is in every single one of the
patients that we studied with Emery
Naser
where there was a significant increase
in the number of words named in a
shortening of the response time to do so
whereas if you target that parse
immediately interior to it just one
centimeter interior the parse opercular
ease of the frontal lobe particular then
what you get is the opposite effect if
we just go back to the image for a
second to point out the parse
triangularis shows activation the parcel
per calories does not and the in the
fMRI perhaps because the parser in
Belarus is inhibiting the parts of
particular is him if you do DTI rec
instructions at least you find
connections we don't know for sure that
they are inhibitory now in that case in
this case though what Martin did was ask
the question so what happens if you
don't just do one session what happens
if you take these people that had a
stroke ten years prior and
ten days of stimulation daily sessions
of stimulation if you do that the number
of items that they name spontaneously in
a separate battery of words improves and
sustains for for two weeks
if you then couple it with another ten
days of stimulation plus constraint
speech therapy which is very frustrating
to this patient say that it means
including the objects that they are
supposed to to be describing and naming
and having them not be able to show you
a point to it I'd rather have to come up
with with the words him so if you couple
it that way even though they were 10
years after the stroke and all had had
speech therapy three months later there
any more items eight months later they
named even more items without further
stimulation suggesting that at least in
some instances in the case of of
language pattern of recovery for some
patients there might be processes that
take place that you know have different
meaning some of them here if you
increase activity there it proves to be
adaptive they improve on their on the
speech output but others a lot of
activity on the right side may actually
be the very reason why they don't
recover further and they think of it as
is maladaptive and we have the the tools
at least to approach the patient's
identifying the substrates of their
dysfunctions and suppressing as a test
experimental level but as a personalized
experimental level
approaching those dysfunctions and
asking whether you may help them
identify a potential therapeutic
intervention I think of this is really
just proof of principle in the in the
case of the nonfluent aphasia is far
from being established as a therapeutic
approach if but but for some of the
other things listed there
there is more data and I won't go into
the clinical application further but for
depression identifying the dorsolateral
- until general sort of disconnection or
functional in disconnection and
targeting it it appears to be effective
enough for medication refractory
depression patients that there are now
four fda-approved systems for 40 ms and
it's insured covered pain and migraine
there is an approved device a and the
long list of studies on going to try to
target different components of of
symptoms in the setting of disorders
that may benefit patients what I like to
do though for the rest of the talk is
not go more into clinical applications
but try to argue that in addition to
localizing symptoms and understanding
the basis of the dysfunction in patients
and potentially developing therapeutic
applications these approaches also for
translatable phenotypes that allow us to
go back to that reverse engineering
model and and ask mechanistic questions
in animal models to bring it back to to
humans and of course the challenge of
the translatable phenotypes is
substantial in in neurology and
psychiatry as you you all know
approaches that go from model inside say
whatever the model is into humans have
traditionally failed and in the
therapeutic approaches that we have
currently for the most part
serendipitous discoveries rather than
actually drug development approaches
from animal models and and perhaps one
of the reasons for it is that the bridge
between the patient and the model the
often times is is inferential we assume
that a mouse struggling to find the
platform
is a good model for depression I don't
know I don't have depression but that's
not what the patient's tell me is their
main problem so I wonder whether our
phenotyping of the patients is poor in
our identifying of substrates in animal
models is it's based on very different
questions that we ask the animals to do
so if you had the same exact measures in
the animal model as you do in the human
that might be a particularly appealing
bridge between the two and I'm going to
try to show you that non-invasive brain
stimulation allows us to do exactly that
you can probe the same exact question
with TMS for example in a human as you
can in a mouse
now I've shown you examples of targeting
an area in humans the aphasia case to
try to modify activity there have an
impact at a distance not just locally
even this is working cats from Antony
Valero from a number of years ago using
2d oxy glucose sustaining it targeting
the bishop parietal cortex with sham
simulation 1 Hertz repetitive TMS or 20
Hertz repetitive TMS and you can see
that the targeted area there is either
decrease in to the Aqsa glucose uptake
or an increase in to the oxy glucose
uptake but you can also see when you use
the animal model is that the impact is
not just local in the targeted area but
at a distance there are specific areas
of altered a uptake of the 2d of the
glucose for example here the spleen your
visual area shows a lack of uptake
whereas neighboring areas shall
perfectly find a uptake and what Tony
was able to do is relate those distance
impacts to the connection to the
connectivity in anatomical connections
to the visual parietal cortex targeted
in this particular case there is a lot
of connections that are excitatory if
you suppress activity in the visual
parietal cortex you can predict that by
decreasing activity there there will be
a withdrawal of that input to the spleen
your visual cortex and thus decrease in
metabolic activity there and what Tony
was able to do is estimate eclis look at
this and show a very nice correlation
between the strength of the anatomical
projections and their sign I'm not
showing you that here and that is an
impact is a connections an inhibitory
and you suppress with a parallel cortex
and what you see is an increase in the
activity distally there are a few areas
that didn't show that correlation that
they're all Ptolemaic and that raises an
interesting question is to what
amplifying additional modulating effect
the ceramic targets may may have in this
argument but we can do the same type of
approach in humans so targeting an area
in anywhere in the cortex recording the
local response with EEG not with the
impact on language or or a motor effect
and looking not just at the local impact
but also at the distributed impact in
terms of the impact of the TMS evoked
potential at the distance at least with
EEG we can do it with very good temporal
resolution but limited largely in the
localization to the surface of the with
much less certainty in deeper areas with
integration of TMS and MRI if we can do
it looking at the bold impact of TMS
applied in the scanner so that if you
stimulate primary visual cortex you can
show an impact and increase alt uptake
in v1 even when you don't evoke
phosphenes when you don't evoke
sensations of light and related to that
an activation of dorsal and ventral
pathways and subcortical structures
so that allows us in humans now to
target different areas and use a
combination of TMS an MRI to ask
questions of how can we reliably reach a
given target in the depth in the same
way that you could in the animal model
with with tawny valorous approach which
are you data from mark Hal Co and
marquel diof you can target a given area
of a default Network parietal cortex or
cerebellar targets based on the
connections to the retros plane your
cortex by targeting these two different
nodes with the same parameters of
stimulation differentially impact
display near visual cortex either
decrease or increase connectivity to
that to that area
however it's never that that easy
unfortunately makes life interesting in
if you think that that's going to be a
predictable effect that will be the same
in everybody well turns out not to be
the case there is a lot of variability
and even in though the local effect we
can measure with this TMS VG's is the
same the same amount of potentiation you
can see here that individual subjects
show sometimes oppression sometimes
increase in the connectivity of the
distance power line is that at least
where we are right now if you want to
modify this connectivity in a reliable
way
if for a given individual you you need
to measure it you need to measure it at
that individual level or you need to
assume that there is going to be a
variety of effects and this it remains
specific to human targets in but them
but there is clearly other individual
factors that we need to to capture now
regardless of that very significant
challenge and the same approach the same
identification of the network targeting
of a given node can be applied across
the lifespan and TMS has been applied to
children newborns
recently born all the way to toddlers
held by the mother and all the way to
aging populations in but in addition to
go back to the argument that was making
you can scale it down and apply it to
rodents to rats or mice and you can
apply stimulation in such a way that for
example it gives you reliably lateral
eyes for poor hind paw a more about
potentials and doing that allows you to
go beyond then start in let me skip this
in measuring interactions between
different pulses what we call pair
pulses stimulation I want to to show you
an example of that in to translate back
to the humans so one of these pair pulse
approaches is shown here you apply a
given stimulus you get a response to it
you apply a second stimulus with a given
integer similar center by 100
milliseconds here and what you get for
the same intensity second stimulus it's
a significantly smaller response to the
to that second conditioned stimulus this
is in the field of TMS they're known as
long interval intra cortical inhibition
we know its interquartile because of
recordings of the descending
corresponding bolus in humans with with
spinal cord monitoring that in sense of
the lázaro has mostly done and they we
don't know the substrate of that it's a
cortical inhibition obviously but by
being able to measure it in the same way
in an animal model we can start as Alex
Rotenberg lab has been doing to
look at modulators of of this inter
critical inhibition and show for example
that gaba a potent shaders or inhibitors
can differentially increase the engine
this leaky inter coracle inhibition or
suppress it and abolish it we can then
go back to the humans and where we can
measure the exact same curve of inter
coracle inhibition and facilitation and
as the question is there a condition
where we might find an abnormality in
leaky and where we can reverse engineer
that finding using it as a bridge in the
animal model sim and in the humans so to
that end let me illustrate the argument
with this word from from Hugo theory
Hugo has been interested in the question
of what happens immediately after a
concussion and and he's looked at these
pair pulse stimulation paradigms and
showed that short interval inter coracle
inhibition and short interval inter
coracle facilitation when they interval
between those two pulses is just 2 or 10
milliseconds respectively
there is no abnormality in those
measures after a concussion but if you
look at that licky that I was talking
about at long intro cortical inhibition
in a healthy control or somebody that
has had a concussion and recovered you
get a certain amount of suppression of
the response to the first stimulus but
in a Comcast recently come Casa athlete
you get a much greater amount of
inhibition there is almost an abolition
of that response and you can to study
with 20 plus say individuals and
repeatedly show indeed after the
concussion there is this this looks
transient but this acute alteration of
the inter coracle inhibition so with
Alex Rosenberg we've been interested in
in asking the question what is a
substrate for this can we use this
measure
as a sort of translatable physiologic
phenotype and and demonstrated in an
animal model and get at a mechanistic
insight as to what what is causing it so
using a fluid percussion injury model in
rats in this case you can cause
different degrees of injury all the way
to mild quote/unquote traumatic brain
injury whatever that is and without
anatomical disruption without
microbleeds but them with the same
abnormality in the leaky that I was just
just showing you in humans with an
abolition of the inter coracle
inhibition and when you when you can
quantify this and when you look then at
the question of what is going on in the
cortex in this individuals work with the
cow hinge Alex was able to show that
that indeed there is no alteration of
the cortical architecture in this model
by design really you can make the
percussion stronger but there is a
significant loss in par what we mean
cells that that affect the GABAergic
circuitry and and that presumably is the
dysfunction that leads to that biomarker
in the in the animal model but also then
in in humans it is because of the
scaffolding of the purple beam in cells
and because of that pursue maybe there
is a possibility of recovering from from
it so there's one example I want to
finish with with another example of
serve this translational approach him
but I've shown you so far is single pole
stimulation and pair policy stimulation
but in the examples at the beginning in
humans I was talking about repetitive
stimulation to modify to modulate a
activity in a given targeted area
you can measure the effect of that
modulation for example you can get a in
this case a motor of a potential you
could use it any G evoked potential to
single pass TMS then apply a train of
stimulation for example theta personal
simulation and then following that train
measure the response again with single
pulses and if you apply it intermittent
therapist in that targeted area you will
get a facilitation of the responses and
if you apply continuous errors you would
get a suppression of the responses but
people now talk about LTP like an Ltd
like plasticity and I personally hate
the terminology and don't know what
exactly it means but the argument I'm
going to try to make is that we can
actually do the same in the animal model
and actually ask the question what is
sustaining or or generating that that
effect let me first show you what we can
do with it in in humans and how it
behaves so if you apply the Train here
and you measure the responses afterwards
not just one example but but over time
after four second train of therapist you
get somewhere between 30 and 40 minutes
of either suppression of the responses
or facilitation of the responses it's
not perfect test retest reliability but
pretty good test retest reliability for
TMS effects a test retest reliability in
the neighborhood of 70 percent of effect
this is actually quite exciting for us
normally we see much worse results you
can use this to measure the efficacy of
the mechanisms of plasticity if that's
what but these are in over their
lifespan because remember we can apply
it in children and we can apply it in
older patients in the same exact way and
Katerina Freitas has done this and shown
not perhaps greatness for any of us that
as we age
almost linear fashion is a progressive
decline in the efficacy of this
mechanisms and the reason why it's
perhaps not very good news is because
Peter freed has shown that that there is
a fairly good correlation between the
cognitive performance of any one
individual as measured by the ADA's cog
and that degree of potentiation after
the therapist but we also know that that
plasticity Williams same source was
correct it needs to be the optimal
amount if you have too much is not good
for you if you have too little is not
good for you and so Lindsey Oberman has
been doing work asking the question
other disorders where there is too much
of this plasticity and and that may may
map and do unto problems and she found
out that individuals with autism
spectrum disorders show here in red too
much potentiation that is way
longer-lasting that in the neurotypical
control and too much suppression that is
way longer-lasting that in neurotypical
controls in fact so much so that when
you look at the time point after 40
minutes of that train of stimulation and
use that as a classifier for a second
cohort of 40 subjects there was a
sensitivity of 98% and a specificity of
98% if a single person was miss
allocated so we've we've gotten
interested in in these measures as ways
to to characterize in mechanisms of
plasticity in again so far no knowing
what the substrate really really is of
any of this
but the peter has continued that the
work and found out that in diabetes type
2 even well control diabetics without
any neurological complications show a
loss of this LTP like the ITBS effects
not of the
Ltd like but of the LTP like abnormality
that maps actually quite well with the
findings of Katie bream in Alzheimer's
disease were patients with early
Alzheimer's disease show the same
dysfunction the same lack of
potentiation after the ITB s train and
perhaps there's a link for the
epidemiologic evidence that the type 2
diabetics have an increased risk of
Alzheimer's disease so very briefly it
snapshot it looks like this potentiation
like effect of the ITB s is excessive in
autism spectrum disorders and suppress
in these two conditions diabetes and
Alzheimer's in this case there is in
addition an excessive Ltd like effect
these cases that's normal it gives us at
least in a clinical level the
possibility of asking the question so
what happens if you improve this if you
try to normalize the plasticity in early
Alzheimer's disease and engage the
subjects then in cognitive training
could that be potentially leading to
therapeutic effects and there is
actually a company that got interested
in pursuing that in Ronix just released
the results a couple of days ago in the
offer of a pivotal trial using trains of
stimulation to different cortical areas
that map on to different cognitive
functions six different cortical areas
and immediately after the training
simulation engaging their subjects mild
Alzheimer's disease patients in
cognitive training when you do that
overall what you see is that if you are
applying real stimulation and real
cognitive training there is a
significant improvement in the ATIS coke
three months after six weeks of
intervention that is not there if you
apply just stimulate just the cognitive
training sorry with a sham simulation
and it's obviously not there if you
apply sham stimulation cognitive
training and that's paralleled with a
change in that potentiation effect that
I was describing
such that the more improvement there is
on the LTP like plus the city the more
cognitive benefit this patients show and
in animal models we can measure the
exact same phenomena if we can apply the
trains in the same way and and we can
then ask the question what are the
mechanisms underlying that LTP like a
plasticity in this work that alex
Rotenberg is currently doing and we
could look at it in quote animal models
of Alzheimer's disease and ask the
question are they real modern sir are
they capturing some phenotypes that
could be reachable between the human and
they and the animal model so just to
wrap it up em I've tried to argue that
non-invasive stimulation combined with
EEG and fMRI and obviously with other
methods of capturing the effects of that
perturbation onto the onto the brain it
can serve as well to examine and
characterize humans neural network
dynamics but because it's applicable in
the same way in animal models allow us
to bridge the gap to the to the model
organisms and then allow us to have
translatable phenotypes in addition that
in humans it allows us to identify
targets for individually tailored
therapeutics therapeutic approaches that
go after the brain circuit dysfunction
not trying to restore it because that
may not always be the therapeutic
approach but sometimes it may be
disrupting a given maladaptive
intervention but we can do so in a
systematic experimental way just to find
out what shows a benefit and then as the
question can we repeatedly apply it in
such a way that it leads to some lasting
effect of course the essential first
step in all of this remains I think a
precise characterization of the clinical
phenotype to allow for that reverse
engineering from symptoms to from
localization and ice up there thank you
very much
[Applause]